we didn't land on Plymouth Rock Plymouth
Rock landed on us Spike Lee and Denzel
Washington made a civil-rights biopic
that's more relevant than ever the way
to press the street Malcolm now compared
to when he was alive as a difference
between night and day only et can take
you inside the making of Malcolm X I
think it's time to stand up break it up
you got what you wanted no I'm not
satisfied
I was nervous by knew what was at stake
and then son I both knew that we were
two right people for the job and we
could do it but you're under tremendous
pressure not to drop the ball in this
one take a real good look at where you
live not just where you live but take a
good look at where everybody you know
live I was fascinated I mean it was
really about 12 years ago when I did a
play about him I read the autobiography
and once I did that I just couldn't get
enough information any and everything
that I could do talk to his family his
friends his brothers and sisters is just
try to live that life and there were
four or five different lives to live
lyndie hopping zoot suit wearing guy the
criminal the convict the young member of
the Nation of Islam the Orthodox Muslim
the marked man Denzel felt we have to
try to give an essence of the man he
cannot be Malcolm next but he'd give the
essence of the man and order do that he
had to be in a place spiritually pure to
Lao mouth and spirit to come through
they've always been those who believed
in accommodation
who believed and compromise Malcolm on
the other hand represented a very
distinct strand of thought and black
opinion that said compromise with
America is impossible and there were a
lot of people who never believed that
black people would be accepted in
American society what's your name no
that's the name of the slave masters in
your family
you don't even know who you are you're
nothing less than nothing who are you
when you say well my name is Denzel
Washington what's it no that's not your
name that's the name that your slave
master gave you that's his name
who are you who are you and if I love
that scene in the film because we don't
know you know and most people just take
these things for granted
he made you think about these things and
how you got here and what your history
was that's the one thing that I've
learned from him more than anything else
probably is to study history that was
one of the more intimidating things the
first time I had to get up in front of a
an audience and speak I mean that's not
something I do myself fresh in one scene
we had like about 2,000 people there and
they kind of looking at me like okay you
know show me that was tough not all of
them but we got these best speeches we
pulled them out and we put him in the
script and we were doing these speech
scenes he would come to the end of the
text and I wouldn't say kind of keep on
going and Denzel would continue for
another 5-10 minutes there's Malcolm
verbage coming out of this mouth and I
was final and say cut and then it'll be
spent and had this blank stare in his
face and he said spike and we said I
just don't couldn't remember what he
said that's the type of spiritually know
thing that then it was working on on
this film man of integrity a man who
educated himself who wasn't a victim of
his circumstances of his earlier
environment and upbringing and really
turned his life around and just really
soared and became a man of service to
his people and would have been to all
people I think the most important thing
was really show the full development of
Malcolm X I think the reason why Malcolm
X in my opinion always been said why he
told your story - Alex Hale he want to
use his life as an example the
african-americans that you too can do
what I did I was a junkie I sold drugs I
did all these bad things but I lifted
myself out of the depths through
education
and then at the time he said because of
religion and that's why he uses life
that example show we can do this from
now when I speak my own words and I
think my own thoughts one of the things
I loved about him was the fact that he
was willing to change his way of
thinking you know when to admit okay
maybe I was wrong about that and then
I'll try this he was a man who was
constantly evolving getting better I
think and growing in many ways and it's
something we can all learn from we're
prepared to work with any groups leaders
organizations as long as they're
genuinely interested in results the way
to press the street Malcolm now compared
to when he was alive as the difference
between night and day because he was
vilified when he was alive I think that
Malcolm is still very much under
appreciated by Americans black and white
part of it is because at that time there
was such dazzling examples of the
leadership all over the place but John F
Kennedy then the Martin Luther King but
I think what Malcolm stood for was a
straightforward commitment to an
expression of manhood because he felt
that America would only work if it was
an America of equals it could never work
if there was somebody on top that's
about in the bottom you're sad because
that was the outcome and there could
have been so many other greater things
but I get a sense of hope because he was
so committed
he had such integrity and we all have
that potential ourselves so there's a
sense of hope when you leave it there's
this thinking among all Americans not
just white America is that because we
have Arsenio Hall Eddy Merckx
ultra Winfrey because you have a couple
black folks who made it through very
high-profile they're very very rich that
means everything is okay in this country
Michael Jordan could be the most
successful athlete in the world then
America still a great you know has to be
more than that what was important is
that we did not want this make this
strictly historical piece a museum piece
african-americans the most part I feel
is still second-class citizens in this
country the reason why Malcolm X is
still popular today is because it's
tough he talked about still
apply today it's an American film I
think truly an American film about an
african-american but an American film
it's a kind of film that makes you think
it sort of sticks with you and I think
that's a good thing